moviegoers of all ages probably
recognize joe pesci from his streetwise
fast talking performances in films like
goodfellas and home alone pesci has
stayed mostly out of the spotlight since
the turn of the millennium but that
doesn't mean he's disappeared entirely
here's the untold truth of joe pesci
born joseph frank pesci on february 9
1943 in newark new jersey joe pesci was
thrown into the spotlight at an early
age by his father angelo who saw show
business as a ticket to giving his
family a better life by the time he was
five years old pesci made his debut on
star time kids a television variety
series that aired from 1950 to 1955. the
experience was by pesci's own
description less than pleasurable in a
1992 interview with the new york times
he said my father loved me so much that
he did not want me to be a laborer or
anything i don't know if it's the right
thing to do push your kids into
something and then stay on them until
they do it let them pick what they want
to do
though pesci was less than enthused
about performing it kept him afloat
during his pre-famed days pesci sang and
played guitar in a string of pop and
rock acts most notably in the touring
version of the popular new york act joey
d and the starlighters which provided
him with his first feature film
appearance as an extra in the band's
star vehicle hey let's twist pesci then
made his bid for pop stardom in 1968
with the release of his first solo album
little joe short can sing but the lp
wasn't a hit so he returned to gigging
alongside another jersey musician frank
vincent however live club music had
fallen out of fashion by the early 70s
so the pair turned to comedy forming the
duo vincent and pesci i'm funny how i
mean funny like i'm a clown i am use you
i make you laugh decades after they hung
up the act vincent would remain pesci's
friend off camera and frequent nemesis
on film pesci brutalized vincent in
raging bull and beat him to death in
goodfellas while vincent returned the
favor by bashing in pesci's skull and
casino
in 1976 heshi had his first credited
movie role in family enforcer also known
as the death collector a low-budget
mafia thriller starring pesci and joe
cortese as muscle for the mob solid
reviews prompted pesci to head to
hollywood but a lack of further success
sent him packing back to the bronx where
he worked as a restaurant manager it was
at this low point that martin scorsese
and robert de niro came calling the
director and star had seen pesci and
family enforcer and sought him out for
their next project the boxing drama
raging bull heshi played joe lamotta the
brother manager and eventual enemy of
short-tempered boxer jake lamotta which
earned him a nomination for best
supporting actor at the oscars the
following year and made his name one to
remember from 1980 to 1998 heshi lent
his unique charm to a handful of iconic
movies from scorsese collaborations such
as goodfellas and casino to comedies
like home alone and my cousin vinnie he
had a small part opposite de niro in the
legendary sergio leone's last film once
upon a time in america portrayed
real-life pilot david ferry and jfk and
had a recurring role as leo goetz in the
lethal weapon franchise however many of
pesci's credits are likely to be total
obscurities to even the most seasoned
moviegoers for instance in 1983 pesci
starred as a bowling alley owner with
dreams of stardom in the west german
musical dear mr wonderful it's also
likely that you miss pesci as the uncle
of the bride in betsy's wedding or his
thinly veiled take on legendary
photographer ouija in the public eye
the takeaway peshi's hits are very big
but his misses disappear with little in
between
pesci has given few interviews since
announcing his retirement so his reasons
for the decision remain solely with him
however it's possible that he simply
lost his taste for the projects that
were being offered to him as far back as
1992 pesci told the new york times that
many of the roles brought to him were
quote stupid ethnic italian parts with
pizza pie stupid jokes while he mostly
avoided that characterization in his
film work pesci did withstand a barrage
of jokes about his height in the dismal
nbc action comedy half nelson heschi was
top billed as rocky nelson an nypd
detective who works for a private
security firm while trying to launch an
acting career the series co-created by
glen a larson paired pesci with saturday
night live alum victoria jackson as a
scattered brain secretary former
football player fred williamson as
rocky's boss and a visibly unwell dean
martin as himself at the time of its
release critic david handler described
half nelson as quote managing to leave
you feeling both bored and soiled which
undoubtedly helped capsize the series
after just seven episodes
joe pesci's oscar win for his portrayal
of gangster tommy devito and goodfellas
helped to wipe away any residue from
half nelson or his other early
obscurities and it's likely that he saw
his win as the start of a new and
improved phase of his career he told the
new york times i love to star in movies
but i want to have good roles it doesn't
help to get starring roles in something
that's no good i mean that will just
kill you although he netted several box
office hits much of his output during
the 1990s was dismissed by critics and
audiences alike attempts to fashion
pesci into a comedic leading man in the
super and go on fishing robust as was
his attempt at tugging heartstrings in
the terminally soggy with honors which
cast him as a homeless man with a big
heart and a scholar's brain by 1998
pesci had clearly lost his patience with
the industry after logging his third and
final turn as machine gun mouthed leo
goetz in lethal weapon 4 which earned
him a razzy nomination he retired from
acting as a full-time profession and
focused his energies elsewhere
okay come on whatever with several
notable exceptions pesci mostly stuck to
his decision to put acting on the back
burner instead he focused his energy on
golf and to the surprise of many went
back to singing in 1998 pesci released
his second album vincent laguardia
gambini sings just for you named for his
character and my cousin vinnie despite
his ill-advised past at hip-hop with the
infamous single wise guy pesci still
proved his musical powers with
renditions of what a wonderful world and
the ray charles number i've got news for
you although critics and listeners alike
largely dismissed the album as a vanity
project pesci kept his hand in music as
joe dogs he earned respectable reviews
for falling in love again a
collaboration with jazz organist joey
defrancesco and held his own alongside
his one-time idol little jimmy scott on
the folks who live on the hill a duet
featured on the legendary vocalists
final studio album i go back home two
years later pesci released his third
album still singing which featured two
duets with maroon 5's adam levine
in a 2016 interview comedy legend don
rickles who appeared with pesci in
casino said of his co-star i think
sometimes he believed he was with the
mob but he got over it given pesci's
multitude of terrifying gangster
performances it's understandable how
some might misconstrue him as a maid man
in the real world while there are tales
of the actor interacting with career
criminals pesci has kept himself out of
trouble off-screen well mostly in 2006
pesci was involved in an alleged assault
against an overzealous fan in florida
according to a police report pesci
struck a man who ignored his request to
refrain from taking his picture but
prosecutors dismissed the allegations
over a lack of evidence a half decade
later pesci was involved in not one but
two legal cases the first in 2012
involved his ex-wife actress claudia
harrow who was sentenced to 12 years for
allegedly hiring a hitman to whack her
second husband stuntman garrett warren
pesci was briefly considered as the
supposed source of financing for the
failed hit though the allegations were
eventually dismissed the following year
pesci was awarded an unspecified court
settlement from fiore pictures after he
sued the company for allegedly reducing
his salary and role in what would become
the infamous 2018 biopic gotti with john
travolta there's no question that joe
pesci is a complicated individual even
he's noted as much in an interview with
the baltimore sun he recalled having an
existential crisis while playing a game
of golf saying i didn't know who the
hell was about to hit that golf ball was
it leo goetz or david ferry or tommy or
harry or joe i spent so much time as
somebody else and so little time is
myself i lost sight of who i was for an
instant pesci is an enormously talented
actor and if his quietly menacing
performance and the irishman is any
indication one's still capable of
mesmerizing audiences well into his 70s
however he seems to prefer to focus on
other outlets that appear to have a
greater hold on his heart including
singing and tending to his own personal
well-being if acting has left him
feeling misunderstood misrepresented and
even unsure of who he really is it's
hard to blame him for choosing to step
away from it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]